President Joe Biden is seeing a big
polling surge within the Democratic
party this is not his National approval
which is still pretty steady around
mid-40s this is when you ask Democrats
who should be the Democratic nominee in
dramatically more Democrats today than
two months ago say that it should be Joe
Biden it appears as though this is for a
number of reasons one it is being led by
younger people number two his recent
visit to Ukraine and speech in Poland
very strong his recent State of the
Union viewed very favorable favorably by
democrats and to some degree I believe
this is strategic I do believe there are
more Democrats realizing
um Shifting the nominee or Biden not
running again and having a long primary
were Democrats fight against each other
it might not be that good for the party
ultimately